-How are you?
-I'm good, I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm well.
A lot has changed since
the last time you were here.
You are a very recognizabl
person now,
even more so than I think
the last time you were here.
And I feel like as someone o
the Intelligence Committee
when you're this recognizable,
it kind of means at its core
that something's gone wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, it can. It can.
-Do you find that
you're recognized more?
-Oh, yes.
In fact, I had a rather
unusual experience
on my way here tonight.
I was on the phone with
one of the major airlines,
trying to get back
into my account,
because I couldn't remembe
the password.
So I finally get through.
-You're on
the Intelligence Committee
I just want to remind you that
[ Laughter ]
-It is a little scary.
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
-Well, the password was so
secret that not even I could -
-Sure, sure, sure, right.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I'm on the phone.
I finally get through
all the voicemail hell.
And I get this disembodied voice
walking me through the login
screens, whatever.
And I'm entering
a new security question.
And the question is, "What i
your first dog's name?"
And I enter the dog's name
but it's too short.
It won't accept it.
So I say, "Won't accept
my dog's name."
So the voice says,
"Try 'impeach.'"
And I said, "What?"
And he says, "Try 'impeach.'
And I said, "I thought
that's what you said."
"I was trying to be
very professional,
but I couldn't help."
I said, "I'm not going to us
that as the dog's name."
[ Laughter ]
But, yes.
-Yeah.
So even your voice on the phon
with a major airline,
they know who you are now.
-They apparently do.
-They apparently know
who you are.
I think one of the things,
obviously --
The Latin term
we're all familiar with no
is quid pro quo.
We even had, you know, durin
some of the testimony,
Gordon Sondland
basically laid it out.
This is a Trump appointee.
He said,
"Yes, there was a quid pro quo."
And yet, a lot of
the Republicans,
most of the Republicans
in the committee,
still continue to say
there was no quid pro quo,
that it is clear as day,
as some would say, there is,
it is just as clear to the
there isn't.
Is this a -- Do you think they
at their core believe this
or is this just a gaslightin
maneuver to let their --
let their base,
let the President,
know that they have
their backs in this?
-Mostly the latter.
I don't think they really
believe this.
And we had exactly
that phenomenon
where we had Sondland testify.
He quite clearly said, "Yo
know, most people want to reduce
this to a simple question.
Well, if you do, the answer is
yes, there was a quid pro quo.
-Interesting to know that
I believe it was
in his opening statement.
That was something
that he just offered up.
-Yes, yes.
And nonetheless, Republica
members walked out of
that very hearing saying,
"See, he said no quid pro quo.
And you listen to that
and you think,
"Okay, were you in the same room
that I was in?
Because he very clearly said
'That's exactly
what happened here,
and not only that,
everyone was in the loop.
And what's more,
these were the orders
from the President on down.'
Rudy Giuliani, acting
as his agent, was implementing
essentially this scheme
to condition
the White House meeting.
And then, later,
$400 million in military aid
to help the President coerce
Ukraine into basically cheatin
for him in the next election
It's rare to have
a case this strong,
this unequivocal,
this overwhelming.
And the astonishing thing abou
it is, normally,
a complex white-collar crime
case like this,
and that's what this is
analogous to,
is very document-driven.
But here,
because the White House said
"You get to see no documents,"
we were able to make the cas
with these career public
servants who did their duty,
who came and testified, suffered
the insults and the attacks,
and because of their patriotism,
we know the truth.
And the truth is, the Presiden
of the United States tried t
shake down an ally to help him
cheat in the next election
-So many of these
public servants
either served under
both presidents
or were appointees of
a Republican administration.
Were you surprised as it went on
how quickly they were attacked
for being --
"Never Trumpers" was certainly
the term that was used the most.
Were you surprised that your
colleagues across the aisl
were so quick to attack them
for that?
-You know, I have
the usual sensation we hav
in the era of Trump, which is,
you're shocked on the one hand
you're not surprised
on the other.
-Yeah, that's about where I feel
every night, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You described it well.
-So, you know, here you ha
people like Bill Taylor, who
you know,
as his testimony revealed,
graduated top of his class
at West Point.
He chooses to go to Vietna
during the height of the war
And I loved when he was asked,
because he's so self-effacing,
you know.
"You got some distinctions
while you served in combat."
He says,
"Well, one I'm most proud of
is the combat
infantryman's badge.
You know, I also got
a Bronze Star, but, you know
the one I really care about --
This is a guy who is basically
downplaying a Bronze Star.
-Sure.
-And this is a guy
they're attacking.
Colonel Vindman
got a Purple Heart.
They're attacking him.
Ambassador Yovanovitch
had dangerous posts
around the world.
They're attacking her.
There is nothing
beyond their willingness
to debase themselves
for this President.
And, you know,
I keep making the point,
what are you going to tell you
grandkids when they ask yo
what you did while
this awful man was in office
to stand up to him?
-He doesn't like you.
[ Laughter ]
-I get that impression.
-I don't know if you know that
yeah.
And a lot of
the Judiciary Committee,
a lot of the Republicans there
they actually felt that you --
you had a right to be there,
and you had a right
to answer questions.
And then,
we've referenced the fact
that they have terrible props.
But this is a milk --
a poster board of you
on the side of a milk,
because you were missing.
Now, of course, you weren'
missing. You just were not -
There was no reason for yo
to be there.
And yet, they frame it as though
you're sort of hiding, you know,
somewhere in Congress becaus
you're too afraid to go
in front of this.
Has this been strange to watch
them use you as a prop,
being a colleague of theirs even
though of a different party?
-Well, I mean, the reason is
because this is
what Trump wanted.
So Trump is tweeting out,
"He should be a witness,
he should be a witness."
And they will do
whatever the President asks.
One of my colleagues said,
"We're going to get you
a T-shirt that says,
'I'm right here'
that you can wear on the House
floor and just point to it."
But you know, my favorite sign
frankly, was one
a couple of days
earlier that said,
"It's been zero days since
Adam Schiff followed the rules,"
which means that I was
constantly following the rules
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm like, "Okay, finally
an accurate sign."
But my staff member said,
"Did you see the signs
whatever today?"
And actually, I never paid
attention to the signs.
You know, I just tried to keep
my focus on the witnesses.
-That means the signs
aren't working.
The whole reason you make sign
is for people to see them.